I think it's difficult not to engage
with art we don't want to think that the
world is a place where there's always a
right answer well events in Ukraine have
perhaps suggested that the Western
decline is you know perhaps less
precipitate than the Chinese leadership
might think now there is some evidence
that those epigenetic changes can be
inherited into the Next Generation
[Music]
you know when we oppose relativism moral
historicism relativism and and uh this
fundamentalist objective morality did
you notice that
if you take absolutely dogmatically
objectivist morality like some religious
fundamentalists it's the most
distracting relativism that you actually
introduce into social life because no
argumentation counts is just a pure
conflict quickly quickly at some level
then would you agree or not very limited
level but I think at some level
a little bit of moral Dogma dogmaticism
could be helpful bothering by this
something very simple like there is
maybe some progress conditionally in
this fact I read somewhere a very good
feminist point that
measured by today's standards
feminist and so on
80 to 90 percent of the sex still
the 20th century would be considered
rape by today's standards so is isn't
there nonetheless progress when certain
things are accepted in a good sense
dogmatically like I would like to live
in a society like this where you don't
have to argue you shouldn't torture
people women shouldn't be raped if you
need to argue for it it's already we are
already
losing something this is why what
horrified me is that although who did
this declare in your who and then Trump
you remember how some 10 15 years ago
when all of a sudden torture became a
topic of debate maybe if we do it in the
soft way water board blah blah blah and
even if the majority was opposed to it
this was even more horrible it became a
topic of debate not to mention rape who
was always forget his name he's not my
best friend some American senator who
claimed there is no rape because for
rape there must be penetration there is
no penetration without the woman getting
wet which means she accept the moment we
debate for it we are lost at last the
last thing
when we talk about uh
objective
research I still think that here this is
philosophical problematic maybe to you
and to you we should what horrifies me
most is examples when
factual truth about
what is really out there uh
serves as clearly an instrument of
something we don't agree with like
racism and so on like an example if I
were to be a pro Neo-Nazi German I
guarantee you that I could write a book
full of facts only facts where I say
wait a minute it's not so simple look at
the statistic 60 of journalists in early
30s were were Jews and so on and so on
so the true question here when we cite
anti-Semitism it's not the question of
objectivity are facts really like that
the way anti-semite describes them my
point is the moment you accept this as a
topic of a debate you sold your soul to
the devil
[Music]
I want to think that the world is a
place where there's always a right
answer and that we're being led by the
nose to do this as opposed to that we
want the freedom
to find meaning within a kind of
constraint offense that the world
creates for us
so we want certainty to be just here
and we want the freedom inside to find
meaning so if you think about the
junctures in your life where you have to
make important decisions or you have to
know stuff that's really important
for how things unfold
those are cases where
you have uncertainty you have no clue
how things are going to turn out
but is uncertainty really what's
problematic imagine God or some
omniscient being who could see the two
Paths of your future and one you move
you up your family you take on this new
job and the other
you carry on As You Are
right
there are pros and cons
there'll be a better school district for
your kids
um you'll make more money
you'll lose the specific attachments
your kids will hate you forever because
they don't want to leave their friends
right and the truth of the matter may be
from a God's eye point of view
that you know it's just not true that
One path is better than the other and
nor should we think
ah they're the same just go ahead and
flip a coin so
the uncertainty our lack of knowledge
about all the details of these two
alternative paths we can take that's not
the problem the problem is the fact that
the value of these two paths are
qualitatively really different and
neither is better than the other
[Music]
nobody comes up in the morning wakes up
in the morning goes to the mirror and
and does the Disney villain thing like
whoa what kind of evil can I do today
no they they think they're doing the
right thing I mean Putin has
justifications to himself and to the
world for what he's doing and so did
Hitler and so the Mussolini etc etc the
question therefore is well should we buy
those justifications but Define the
right thing because that I think when we
say these people believe that they're
doing the right thing the right thing
for whom because ultimately you know and
I and I think this is what kind of you
were touching it as well right it's like
even in the the multiple multiple
Western Traditions around good and evil
and their meaning ultimately a lot of
the philosophy is hidden behind the
concept of universality to justify the
validity of those Concepts while
simultaneously not applying them in a
way that has been Universal and so it's
almost like difficult to criticize the
principles if they simultaneously claim
to be Universal while not actually some
sort of negating it yes yeah but I don't
think they did right I mean so so like I
don't think of Hitler as a Universalist
or or Putin as a Universalist and if
they think of themselves that way they
just don't understand what universalism
actually is so no I think that if we
take universalism is more
cosmopolitanism or however whatever word
you want to use seriously then it really
does follow that certain actions are not
not acceptable and I don't see how one
could reasonably use them use those
ideas as in defense of those actions the
fact that people do anyway because lots
of people don't reason particularly well
or they don't pay particular attention
to philosophy or or facts on the ground
that's that's a fact of human life but
no I cannot honestly imagine somebody
who says I'm a Cosmopolitan therefore
I'm entitled to kill half of the world
because they don't look like me that's
like I just don't understand that's a
very common Cosmopolitan idea for Europe
in a certain period no it isn't it is
absolutely not for example so for
example no I mean it actually is I mean
my second book was on how Josiah Royce
literally introduces the notion of
cosmopolitan is an idealism on the basis
of enslaving a whole group of people in
the early 20th century and he had this
debate even at the University of
Aberdeen in their philosophical Society
like trying to figure out how
anglo-saxonism could be extended over
German idealism as a justification for
our Anglo-Saxons democracy right but
what that is is a very good example of
rationalization right but you but you
have centuries and centuries of right
but this is what I mean say like you're
in our time we're saying that this
doesn't fit with what we think the
rationalization would be but then from
the 18th to 19th century you have all
the letters and the and the premier
institutions of Europe that are centers
of philosophy endorsing the very same
argument this is this is what I mean
it's a perspective of time it's a
perspective of how context and
perspective shifts is socially
undesirable for us to make that
admission now and what we say is that
that wasn't rational or philosophically
rigorous but even Nazism will start to
be a product of a certain idealist
tradition Houston story Chamberlain
actually defected from an Anglo-Saxon
Burr to support a German file tradition
precisely on the basis they thought
idealism was a more active sentiment of
the Universe on the one in the society
that it can actually create a unified
notion of a folk so we have to be
careful with suggesting that those are
all mistakes when that's a progression
of the kinds of ideas these traditions
and the plurality of the West that you
think exists but somehow don't become
taken up
[Music]
what we do as scientists is take our
best theories and look at their
implications so our best theories right
now are Evolution with natural selection
and also Quantum field Theory and
gravity and these these theories speak
with a uniform voice
space-time is not fundamental it could
not be fundamental those Theory so our
best scientific theories themselves are
telling us that space-time is not
fundamental
so there's got to be a deeper story
there's something Beyond space-time and
physicists by the way are finding very
interesting structures the amplitohedron
cosmological polytopes these structures
actually explain the data inside space
and time but they have no notion of
space and time not even any notion of um
Gilbert spaces so there's no quantum
theory so there so what we're going to
find is that we have to have a deeper
Theory beyond space and time when we
project it into space and time it will
look like evolution by natural selection
it will look like Quantum field Theory
and and gravity so so this is the the
framework in which I'm thinking about
Consciousness may be that deeper story
foreign
[Music]
crazy it was his action in invading
Ukraine crazy in in my view yes I think
that someone who had until then be more
or less a rational if extremely cynical
actor in his own country's national
interests became at that point
irrational and self-destructive I don't
think he's crazy I don't think he goes
around smearing feces on the walls of
the Kremlin but I do think that he has
lost his reason and that we are now
dealing with somebody in a position of
great power Whose actions cannot be
reliably predicted by any calculus and
and that that seems to me to be a very
important but I have to say this by the
way because I had previously so many
times said that his actions were both
predictable and rational because the
other part of the question do we fail to
understand or not listen to what other
people are saying is an absolute valid
question about the attitude of many
Western countries towards Russia since
the collapse of Communism in 1991 we
have taken a view or rather the United
States especially since the expansion of
NATO has taken a view which which many
people who are very far from being
sympathetic to Putin or his invasion
will accept was provocative the problem
we have is that on the 4th of February
many people don't yet realize this for
the fair but the Olympics
Xi Jinping and Putin met and issued a
joint statement saying that what I've
just said is [ __ ] that there are
from now on in three modernities there
are three different at least three
definitions of democracy three
definitions of Human Rights they said um
we allow our population to have a say in
them how things are are run by us that
is our definition of democracy and who
are you to say that there is an
objective one furthermore they say
notwithstanding that their signatures
still lie on the universal convention
the UN Universal Declaration of Human
Rights notwithstanding the fact that
they are signatories to that and that
Russia was a signatory to the to the
European convention they say
there are three definitions of human
rights as well so what is before we even
get to what we do about Ukraine the
point has been for me to frame Ukraine
within that there is a declared systemic
conflict you have no choice over that
whether you think the West is beautiful
and should should have ruled the world
forever or whether you think it's
terrible the fact is there are no three
upcompeting modernities and you live
most of you in the west and you'll have
to decide whether or not the thing you
want to do with your life whether it's
to open a small business study medieval
history whatever live a hedonistic
lifestyle can exist in either of the two
other
systems and that might put to you that
it can't and that therefore the Ukraine
conflict which was not chosen by NATO it
wasn't chosen by Ukraine it was chosen
simply and purely by Vladimir Putin who
I think does have a rationality because
his his regime has become a regime of
Crisis it has moved in a fascistic
totalitarian Direction when previously
it was a nationalist populist autocracy
because there's only 20 years of the of
the fossil fuel era left that's only 20
years left for that kind of society to
exist
he has to in order to prove to the must
base that Russians you know are
ethno-nationalistically Supreme in
Eurasia he has to wipe out the Ukrainian
identity now I'm I've opposed every war
even the faultless I shocked some of my
colleagues Falklands but
I don't see any alternative to the West
standing with Ukraine
[Music]
I think that we are coming closer to a
tipping point at which the Chinese
leadership May conclude that peaceful
reunification is no longer an option I
don't think we're there yet but I think
that everything that the United States
has done over the last two or three
years has probably brought us closer to
that Tipping Point than we previously
were
um and the other thing I mean Chris
mentioned 2035 Xi Jinping is a man with
a sense of history and Legacy he is
going to try to get a third term as
Secretary General of the Communist party
at the end of this year and he almost
certainly will will achieve it and he
may well you know go on and go get a
fourth term out after that but he's not
a young man he's one year younger than
me
um and yeah exactly
um you know gerontocracy beckons
um you know
if he wants to if he wants to get be the
guy who goes down in history as having
accomplished this he's actually got to
get moving
um and I don't think that a date has
been set but 2035 sort of lends itself
as a date because essentially China's
realization of its Centenary goals has
in practice been brought forward to them
so I agree with Nigel's analysis about
the balance of calculation on one side
on the other side though I would say
um that covid this year has really taken
up a lot of bandwidth in the Chinese
government you know we're here masculus
Teslas
um vaccinated and it's not the situation
in China you know if you look at what's
happened to Shanghai that is not going
to they're not changing their policy on
zero covered anytime soon so that's
going to take up a lot of government
bandwidth and it's also eroded a lot of
the government's legitimacy I think in a
lot of the eyes of the middle class
Chinese who thought well we're wealthy
now we're Educators they couldn't
possibly you know do the kind of
political rights erosion they used to do
but well you know they just have so I
think that's taken up a lot of bandwidth
and made people question legitimacy
inside a party and inside the country
and also the economy as a result is
tanking you know the Chinese economy is
expected that governmental Target is 5.5
this year it sounds like a lot but it's
the lowest in three decades and they
might not even reach that and they
actually almost certainly will not reach
that given zero covered so given what
Nigel was saying about this being
critical year for cesian pains
continuation in power I don't think he's
going to want to rock the boat even more
by you know a dragged out war in Taiwan
at least not before he gets consummated
in October or November whenever the
party Congress is um but that's not to
say that that ticking clock is right you
know he does have a historical sense of
himself so I don't know all I can say is
that on the balance of things on the
other side
that would be holding him back
[Music]
whenever we turn we see capital
making gains over labor over Society
over our democracies
and here I am with an outrageous thesis
that capitalism is on the way out
now
where am I coming from
let's begin with capital shall we now
what's capital it's of money
it's not
a kind of um
Divinity uh it's something very tangible
economists and I used to be an economist
up but fairly recently we defined
Capital as Goods that have been produced
for the purposes of assisting in the
production of other Goods in other words
produced means of production that was
what capital was
Robertson cruises salvaged fishing gear
infection a farmer's plow back in
ancient times in future times today a
Smith's furnace or Hummer
these were are manufactured goods that
help reduce a larger catch of fish more
food shiny stilly tools
this is what capital has always been
capital of course preceded capitalism
capitalism is a system
a mode of production and distribution of
goods and services
uh in which the power
to compel others to do things
uh is vested in those who have ownership
over capital goods in the previous mode
of production at the feudalism power
sprang out of ownership of land
with the transition the great
transformation from feudalism to
capitalism increasingly power shifted
from those who had land to those who
owned capital goods
capitalism
vested the owners of capital with two
new
Powers the first Power was to compel
those who did not have Capital to work
for them that's the whole point of being
a capitalist
your ownership of capital goods means
that you have
the power the bargain power over
people who do not own capital goods who
only the only Capital that they have to
offer is their own human labor to work
for you the second power
of course is the power of the capitalist
class of those who own the majority of
capital goods
to set the agenda
and to set the agenda in the village
fora where big important decisions are
taken on behalf of everyone
in the past and the feudalism it was the
landowners that had the power to set the
agenda
my hypothesis which I want to share with
you and to try to explain and to
convince you about
is that we now have a new form of
capital
when I say now I mean the last 10 15
years or so a new form of capital I
shall be arguing is emerging
and as it does as it emerges as it does
so it is forging a new ruling class a
spanking new ruling class
even a new mode of production
[Music]
in the case of genes we know that if you
if you mutate a gene then it will change
the phenotype
more importantly for an evolutionist
that change Will Go On to the Next
Generation and the next and the next and
the next and potentially forever
um whereas if you change anything else
no matter how important it may be
causally in the embryology of the animal
if you break a leg
circumcise a penis do anything else it
will not be transmitted into future
generations and that's the crucial
difference genes are causal in the sense
that a change in a gene a mutation
has a statistical consequence
in in an indefinite number of future
Generations now the reason that matters
is that natural selection
chooses between Alternatives and the
choice between Alternatives only matters
if
it is potentially Immortal or at least
if it goes on for a very large number of
generations
the near darwinian
Theory which Dennis has a lot of
criticism of in his in his book
is a theory of differential survival of
genes in gene pools
and that only matters if the genes are
potentially able to survive in the gene
pool for a very long time the ones that
do survive are the ones that are that
have a beneficial causal influence on
everybody in which they find themselves
successive Generations the genes find
themselves in bodies again and again the
ones that have survived over many
generations will be the ones that have a
causal influence on a long succession of
bodies and now shut up
foreign
most of the ways I think about what
we're doing in modern physics are from
the perspective of thinking about
ourselves as physical systems because
I'm interested in the Life problem so a
lot of the paradoxes that emerge in
modern physics can be thought about from
a different perspective if we think
about math itself as a physical system
so what is it for uh physical systems to
emerge that then write down laws of
physics and describe those by
mathematical statements and from that
perspective mathematics itself looks
like a kind of information it can be
copied between different things so this
is a very sort of concept that I think
David has talked about quite a bit
um that it can be copied between
different physical systems and then you
can ask questions about why the concept
of infinity would exist from that
perspective and I think Infinity as a
physical concept is not it's a metaphor
in the sense that George was talking
about that it's it doesn't describe
something real physical out there there
is no such thing as a physical Infinity
but Infinity exists as a kind of
information that we can use to
manipulate matter and to understand
properties of the universe as it exists
here and now as sort of a counterfactual
property or allowing us to see where
we're missing things in our measurements
or where there needs to be a new
creative solution so I think it has a
kind of physicality in the sense that
obviously it exists in our minds but it
doesn't have the kind of physical
locality of what it in our minds
represents in the world it's something
else and if we can figure out why
Infinity is a useful Concept in terms of
what it's doing when we write down laws
of physics and maybe how it enables more
creativity for identifying where our
laws of physics are breaking down or
thinking about counterfactual
possibilities then we might be able to
rein in infinity and understand a little
bit more about why and and how it
behaves and what it's doing
[Music]
in your view Consciousness in the brain
arises out of the collapse of the wave
function can you explain that puzzling
claim what does that mean exactly
well they're sort of reasoning behind
why I think that view if you like or I
can say more about what the view is I
mean the reasoning behind it
had to do with the issue of
it really came from my attendance of a
course of lectures given by a man called
Steen
in Oxford it's not in Cambridge when I
was a graduate student in Cambridge and
I went to three courses of lectures
which were nothing to do with the topic
I was supposed to be doing which was
algebraic geometry
and I went to a course by Bondi on
gender relativity which was certainly
very relevant to what I did later
lectures by Dirac on quantum mechanics
where I did the puzzle of the collapse
of the wave function was became more
evident to me and of course on
mathematical logic by a man called Steen
and his lectures
made clear to me at least what seemed to
be clear to me but
conscious understanding
could not be an algorithmic process
there's something different
from computational
processes going on so if
we believe that whatever we are of May
we're sort of physical structures
then do we act according to
computational laws or is there something
in the laws of physics which is outside
that and the view I maintained that time
because of the lectures scenes lectures
on mathematical logic and girdle's
Theorem it it seemed clear to me
that conscious understanding had to be
something which was not computational
and then the question is if it is a
physical process of some sort what could
that physics be and
if I think about classical Newtonian
mechanics it didn't seem to give you
much chance
even gender relativity because you could
put these things on computers there is a
bit of an issue about the fact that
theories depend on continuous parameters
whereas computation as normally
understood is a discrete process
and the way we do calculations in
physics to mirror what's going on in the
world and put them on computers
we regard these as approximations which
you could refine as much as you like
and they're still then computational
processes there is a little bit of a
problem there
about whether there might be a distinct
difference in continuous Evolution from
discrete processes but I didn't think
that was the answer
seemed to me that there had to be
physical processes which were not
computational
and uh
the view is that this is conscious
understanding has to be one of these
and where in physics do we see anything
not computational or anything of
relevance that would be not
computational and uh
it seemed to me it had to be the
collapse of the wave function
oh
foreign
was referring to when he was talking
about the gravitational waves in the
early Universe I suppose it was the B
modes in the CMB is that right
no no what are the future generation of
space-based Revenue detectives like Lisa
laser interferometry space antenna being
pushed by the European Space Agency in
NASA yeah but what's the sigma
primordial gravitational waves
that's right recreational weight before
300 000 years after the big bang at the
instant of creation itself
yeah um right so so why would this be
evidence for the Multiverse I suppose
because you say would be evidence for a
particular type of inflation is that the
idea no because once you have data from
a trillionth of a second after the big
bang you could run the videotape
backwards and see what alternate
universe is the trillionth of a second
before the Big Bang match the data a
trillionth of a second after the big
bang and so in other words in this sense
we can actually get data from before
creation itself from before T is equal
to zero by extrapolating post Big Bang
radiation through the pre-big bank era
and then of course String Theory gives
you a number of predictions about the
free big bang universe that's what
strings did regards and if you find that
result for everything and so you can
actually calculate the free Big Bang
radiation and compare it with the
post-grid bank radiation of gravity
space-based gravity detectives yeah but
what's it got to do with the Multiverse
because this allows you to extract out
the key universe that set the whole it's
everything in motion and that you know
which of the Multiverse ideas with the
correct one just like Newton's Laws
Newton's Laws has an infinite number of
solutions or baseballs rocket ships or
marbles an infinite number solution
which one is the correct one it depends
on your initial conditions we do not
know the initial conditions of the Big
Bang itself once we have the initial
conditions of the Big Bang then you can
start to rule out uh universes that are
that don't match and out of the
Multiverse you can you can get the birth
of our universe itself
so starting with the Multiverse Theory
you then get the theory of the universe
itself
by running the videotape backwards
well but obviously just to describe our
own Universe we don't need all the other
infinitely many universes so um but this
can help to rule out all the other
universes that are do not correspond to
the experiment
well maybe maybe let me step back a
little bit so I'm not saying that
um all those other universes do not
exist
I'm trying to say that science can't
tell us anything about whether they
exist or do not exist it's just not in
the realm of science I don't have a big
problem when people talk about
multiverses of whatever type if that may
be the many words interpretation or
Eternal inflation or the string theory
landscape and so on I get a problem if
they say it's it's science because it
isn't it's a weird kind of platalism
where scientists come to believe in the
existence of mathematics well as I said
every year as more data comes in from
primary lab from CERN every year we'll
have better and better data which will
allow us to zero in on this Theory
without having to build an accelerator
decided the Milky Way galaxy
foreign
working for the government as a drugs
advisor in
1994 when we had a few deaths from MDMA
and that committee was actually quite an
effective committee because we basically
recommended free water in all venues
which still happens today the fact you
can always get
tap water in pubs or restaurants was
part of the process that we put through
to reduce the harms of MDMA and we also
recommend you chill out rooms and that
was an amazing public harm message
because virtually no deaths from MDMA in
the in the subsequent step 20 30 years
except when people tried to stop it and
uh various novel forms such as PMA which
have come along but MDMA itself you can
deal with the harms of MDMA sensibly by
allowing people to get it in a situation
where they can be protected and as a
result of that I was asked to advise
several government committees on how we
should deal with other drugs and I was
full of enthusiasm you know there was a
rational response to MDMA so let's I
assume there'd be a rational response to
other drugs but I when I started looking
at it I realized that actually the drugs
which had already been made illegal you
could not have a rational discussion
about
and why is that that is because if you
try to change the the legal status of a
drug that is illegal the newspaper the
right-wing press go in go insane
and of course the most classic example
of that was when
um we were eventually allowed to
seriously discuss the legal status of
cannabis cannabis until
2004 some forms of cannabis were Class A
alongside
crystal meth and crack cocaine and some
forms of cannabis were a Class B
and after quite a detailed assessment
The Advisory Council which I was on at
the time said they should all be Class C
and the newspapers went insane and they
they desperately tried to stop that
happening but that
um blanket was a home secretary at the
time and he he pushed that through
because he realized that that was what
the science said
but subsequently the media backlash
terrified Blair and then Brown and the
subsequently Cameron and May and since
then governments have always been
absolutely terrified of loosening
I would say be more rational about the
classification of any drug and
eventually cannabis got regraded and
that's how I got sacked for proposing
that and subsequently now we've been
pushing more and more drugs into the
legal category in fact under Theresa may
we brought in this completely bizarre
piece of legislation which says anything
apart from alcohol that affects your
brain it's actually illegal even if even
if it's never been invented so so it's
the drugs drug laws are they have they
have two roles they fulfill the need of
many aspects of the media to to find
someone to hate and something to hate
and get banned and then they serve a
kind of political purpose that
politicians can pretend they're doing
something they can make a law even
though the law actually is probably
going to do more harm than good
foreign
[Music]
works and people most people here will
have been in in gigs that work
brilliantly maybe even here and felt
it's almost a Holy Experience at times
you feel you're all part of a single
moment it can feel like a religious
experience because you're all together
and when a comedian dies it's very
interesting because it's like the air
Thins and you know we all die especially
at the beginning of our tourism I was
once paid 20 pounds to leave the stage
in Edinburgh festival and it's going so
badly
um but actually they're very important
when you're learning those experiences
you have to tell yourself
um when they are very important because
you're finding out who you are and you
have to be truly vulnerable in stand up
and I think that the times that stand
Up's disappointing is where they're not
reaching out in that way they're not
giving you enough vulnerability and it
feels weird in some ways to say that you
have to be vulnerable as a stand-up it
seems like a very powerful thing but
actually it's a delicate line uh that
you have to tread you have to offer
enough of yourself so that's similar
thing the comedian may be very different
from you as a member of the audience
they may be talking about something that
you have no experience of but you will
find that that point at which you feel
truly connected to it what I find very
interesting is when people like Robin
ince who are Comedians and also become
very immersed in the world of science
make shows where science and create
creativity meet because my father was a
chemist who was a very scientific man
and um he he didn't really like Blurred
Lines he didn't like it necessarily when
things were uncertain or
um so yeah I find it very interesting
when when any kind of creativity and
science meets and and what what that
brings about because on paper it should
clash in some ways but I think it could
be quite an interesting mix well Paul
you do that in all your work you're
using heat like in 1000 things worth
knowing and you have references to
science and so if I bring you on in on
this is that quite important to you to
be able to glean from many disciplines
well it is absolutely and in fact I
think maybe at this point I might begin
to migrate a little bit over to to
another way of thinking about things and
I touched upon it briefly when I
mentioned Joyce's obsession with this
factoid I mean who cares
who cares at the end of the day well he
cared
and he what why did he care because at
some level I think he realized that one
does have to test art against some
notion of reality now I use the term
notion of reality because we know
reality is
actually I think we know reality is
itself a construct on the other hand we
have in our everyday discourse
um it's a term we understand
um now Joyce did not care so much about
the fact that a major component of the
plot of Ulysses
um has to do with a foot and mouth uh
pandemic right in 1904
and he didn't really care that that
actually happened in 1912. he was
willing to overlook that fact in terms
of some other motive
but let's but but I think we are
constantly testing the psychological
verifiability say not only the physical
verifiability of whether or not one can
go down this particular Street and
actually if you turn right you're in
this illustrate
that's one test the psychological
verifiability is this likely to be how a
man might respond to the notion that
someone has been as he comes home at
night and comes down into the area over
the railings and seven Eccles Street uh
Leopold Bloom's home what is he going to
make if anything of the fact that his
wife may have been with another man
oh
God
[Music]